Bonjour à vous !
Je suis heureuse de vous retrouver.
Alors je vais vous parler d'abord d'une petite expérience
que l'on peut faire chez soi,
dans sa cuisine par exemple,
et que beaucoup d'entre vous auront déjà faite, je pense.
Vous prenez une coupelle d'eau
et vous mettez du poivre dessus
de façon à ce qu'il couvre toute la surface.
Puis, au milieu, vous déposez
une petite goutte de liquide vaisselle.
Waouh !!!!
Et maintenant, je vais vous présenter une autre expérience encore plus impressionnante !
Bon j'avoue, c'est pas exactement la même chose.
Mais,
elle met, elle aussi, en lumière
les incroyables effets de la...
TENSION DE SURFACE...
Cette fameuse tension de surface dont je vous parlais
Et bien comme son nom l'indique,
c'est une énergie, une tension
au niveau de la surface d'un liquide ou d'un solide.
C'est ce qui fait, par exemple, que certains insectes peuvent marcher sur l'eau.
Alléluia !
Et c'est aussi ce qui a permis
à une équipe de chercheurs toulousains
de réaliser ces images étonnantes.
Qui a dit que Poésie et Hydrodynamique
ne faisaient pas bon ménage ?
Bon !
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette expérience ?
Revenons à notre tension de surface.
C'est elle qui va déterminer, par exemple,
si une goutte que l'on dépose sur un
solide ou à la surface d'un autre liquide
va perler ou au contraire s’étaler complètement.
En fait c'est une force qui existe à
l'interface entre deux milieux.
Un liquide / un solide, un liquide et l'air ou
même deux liquides différents.
Évidemment les chercheurs de Toulouse
n'ont pas monté une expérience
avec de l'eau, du poivre et du savon.
Ils ont pris un petit récipient rempli d'eau
et ils ont déposé à la surface
une goutte de dichlorométhane.
Du dichlo, pour les bricoleurs.
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que, pour un liquide,
la tension de surface augmente
quand la température diminue.
Et elle dépend aussi de la présence éventuelle de composés tensioactifs.
C'est l'équivalent, en jargon de laboratoire, de notre liquide vaisselle "Secret de printemps".
Dans cette expérience, on a un tensioactif.
Il est ajouté à l'eau et à la goutte de dichlo.
Il porte le charmant petit nom de CTAB.
Bromure de cetyltrimethylammonium.
Celui-là, je vous mets au défi de le placer en soirée.
Lorsqu'on dépose une goutte de dichlo sur de l'eau,
elle commence par s'étaler
en formant un film en expansion
autour de sa partie centrale.
Au lieu de s'amincir tranquillement sur les bords,
ce film forme un bourrelet.
Un bourrelet élégant.
Ce bourrelet élégant va ensuite se fragmenter.
Ce qui va générer un anneau de gouttelettes.
Puis le film se rétracte.
Et le cycle recommence.
Le tout va finir par dessiner une petite fleur.
L'élément clé de cette expérience c'est l'é-va-po-ra-tion.
Le dichlo, qui est en train de s'étaler, va s'évaporer.
Ce qui va faire diminuer la température de façon plus importante au niveau des bords du film.
Et du coup, à cet endroit-là,
la tension de surface va être plus importante.
Et c'est ça qui va former le bourrelet.
"Mais du coup, pourquoi ce phénomène de battement,
ne serait-ce pas lié au caractère volatil du dichlo
à la présence du tensioactif ?"
Excellente question ! Merci Véronique P.
Y en a au moins une qui suit !
Les gouttelettes de dichlo éjectées au moment de la fragmentation du bourrelet
vont abaisser la tension de surface de l'eau,
ce qui va permettre au film de se rétracter.
L'évaporation et le tensioactif
vont ensuite évacuer le dichlo
qui s'est dispersé à la surface de l'eau.
Ce qui fait qu'on va retrouver l'état initial
et le cycle peut recommencer.
Bref !
La dynamique de l'expérience,
les pulsations, la formation de gouttelettes...
Toute cette incroyable chorégraphie de fluides
résulte de la bataille acharnée
entre les tensions de surface qui existent
entre l'air et l'eau, entre le dichlo et l'air,
et, entre l'eau et le dichlo.
Ces chercheurs, un peu poètes, ont d'ailleurs réussi
à créer d'autres gouttes dynamiques
en jouant sur les concentrations de tensioactifs.
La compréhension de ces phénomènes pourrait déboucher sur des applications thérapeutiques
pour délivrer, par exemple, de manière plus efficace
des médicaments au niveau des tissus malades.
Ces recherches pourraient aussi être utilisées dans le domaine de la microfluidique
où l'on cherche à contrôler la forme, les mouvements et l'énergie de différents fluides
à de très petites échelles.
Allez ! Avant de partir,
je vous sers une dernière petite goutte !
Oui ! Ben oui ! Désolée
Faut toujours trouver une blague pourrie pour la fin...
Goutte que goutte !
Et surtout...
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner !